e molto facile pensare che io abbia
fatto un frullato di puffi è che l'abbia
spalmato sul muro in realtà il mio
studio quello che c'è dietro di me lo
sto facendo ci sto mettendo mesi forse
anche anni ma lo sto facendo quale menù
più bello di questo poteva mai esistere
prende tanti ragazzi venuti qui sono i
due sono i geni sono su human full flat
che non ho ben capito cos'è ma va bene a
modifiche posso cambiare il personaggio
che cosa vera è una versione un po più
omosessuale di me abbiamo lo sci lo sci
senza gli occhiali da sci
il poliziotto il poliziotto tornatore
quanto è breaking bad
cosa direi che per quanto riguarda il
personaggio ci siamo non ho
assolutamente idea di che cosa sia
facciamo prima a single player per
vedere di cosa si tratta una figata
incredibile dopo una partenza così poi
si ma se non ci sta la scritta fa la più
piccola ma dio perché c'è la statua di
un tizio che si dimena il birillo ai
programmatori di oggi che problemi hanno
rispetto a quelli di una volta futuro
dei suoi
su questo possa ragionare di passi da
livello a livello schiantando t per
terra che è meraviglioso ma mettiamoci
multiplayer prevedere che succede vabbè
giorno si può chattare in qualche modo
sono svenuto vabbè c'è un tasto per
svenire che mi fa piacere posso tirarti
i pantaloni qualche cosa e non sono
molesto e che mi piace toccare i glutei
ehi ciao come si scrive non saper
scrivere aiuti sono svenuto io non me la
cavo molto bene con gli abbracci cristo
firme come faccio a uccidere una persona
perché c'è un estintore qua
acqua tu sei ma tu sei un genio ma ha
chiesto tizio maledetto molla la leva
vieni pato tengo io sta arrivando gente
sono dei russi sono russi che si menano
vale niente di nuovo
grazie al nostro amico come ha fatto a
fare questa cosa lo scomodo devo
prenderla bravo bravo a fondare arrivati
qua i quali quelli qua
ecco gli argomenti ci sono mai fatto
preso male vorrei guarda come sculetta
mentre fa il suo lavoro
non voglio descrivere questa scena mi
sembri amy segreta aspetta noi grafica
che nervi con wi fi posso ucciderti lo
posso uccidere spingendolo giochi porta
mi stanno attirando le peggio madonne
aspetta smette di in una mano chi non sa
chi non amano fermo fermati aspettavo no
sono un deficiente frate due file
dall'altra parte di roma milano di la
[Musica]
cosa sto vedendo cosa sola cosa state o
bio bio è rimasto schiacciato a di
rimettere lo stick per bloccare la porta
e me le sai prendere le misure se io mi
dicono metti lo stick è ma come si
chiude la porta 20 questo maledetto
stick frate sarà il pezzo di dai ma
l'inizio negativo ma navi abbandonate
qua ti giuro mi se per caso eccomi sé
perché stavo dicendo se per caso vi
raggiungo di nuovo ma doveva ammazzo
cattiva ma come come ha fatto ovvio
ovvio occhio
per questo avrei detto delle cose che
non hanno senso di esistere veloce colpi
dai una mano tenendo aperta la porta
bicchieri aperta la porta
potreste tenere la porta aperta dalla
rega mista l'istinto omicida vostro
videogioco ve lo dico la smettiamo
questo esposto vedendo non credo che si
solleverà mai strumenti così a spettanti
coccolava marzo le famiglie ammettilo
chi ragiona leva per cortesia tiraggio
ma la tira giù prato chieti raggio
faccio io faccio faccio io faccio io non
siete capaci o che tira su salewa morale
vigentina no e sì e chi tira leva gesù o
perfetti la bravo ci voleva da era
difficile c'è quello si era aggrappato
alla mia testa ma dona ti ammazzo a di
riproporre giu la roche se togliessi con
la manina lurida ok grazie ma tutti noi
la molla frate molla ma la spaventa giu
non rileva commissari l'istinto vicina
giocava sta roba metti le mani nel culo
per cortese allora questi problemi ai
della vita spiega boema tua madre morta
ma è la falco e ti sta bene fa mica devo
distruggere il vetro che c'è sotto noti
che devo fare così maledizione si fanno
i fatti incastrarmi fatto ma porca vacca
che ai problemi cosa sta facendo questi
sono scemi uno si è lanciato gli altri
maledizione sono arrivati tutti di là
che è successo ai finito livello tutto
sto casino per finire il livello così ma
vi rendete conto veramente finito sul
serio vabbè tutti svenuti a il
poliziotto se n'è andato meno male
perché non l'ho vista più antipatico
scassa all'oggetto da il gioco geniale
se non mi facesse salire il nazismo nei
confronti di tutti i giocatori tutti
tutti dono morire tutti consentì
intellettivo overnight cause frate st st
s stretta kato al lucchetto madonna
non facciamo una sega vieni via con lui
ha preso breaker a capri sembra come fai
scappare una prigione se un poliziotto
spiegami infatti capire un attimo cosa
sta facendo così gruppo un camino
ma sei scemo perché se un poliziotto non
babbo natale o cosa tocchi devi portare
questo di qua per scalare fino al tetto
non puoi scala la porta lurido idiota
dammi una mano a portar sta roba invece
di stuprare le porte ma che nervi porta
sulle prima cospar sociali fermi
l'embolo arriva dal cielo poi a iaia
vaffan
smettila ritoccarmi birillo che problemi
a frate frate fratte frate no frate
ma la vera sul serio ma che figata extra
un gioco ci prova anche io a jolo l'ho
preso l'ho fatta ma ci credo ce l'ho
fatta io lo vedo quello che ho visto
gioco sia l'apoteosi del nonsense
proprio fatto videogame non ha veramente
senso che sembra riguarda delle scimmie
ammaestrate raga la cosa più brutta che
abbia mai visto dei problemi
madonna tua madre ti picchiava quando
eri piccolo occhio non l'ho presa e
coordinazione della bradipo mamma mia
cosa dobbiamo fare
al caf di cagliari arriva alla giorno ma
impossibile fra ok il poliziotto è morto
male occhio bene bene ma l'arbitro dopo
alla madonna al manto grigio vi giuro
vado nel suo paese di morte la russia li
sta minkia lo scorso vivo kiss cuoio
luxor inutile
ecco la tiratura con cristoni subito
dopo guarda guarda guarda non ho idea
non ha idea della goduria non ha idea la
cima tv rende conto del disagio di
quell'uomo
all'edizione ce l'ho fatta a divi
attaccati all'elica che figata assurda
se lo faccio ecco che il geniale sparò
va bene è povero tronco che t'ha fatto
dove l'altro la smetti di file farmi
titoli dalla vita porca no no no da
mazzotta mazzotti giuda marzo metti la
smetta ritocca smetti a marana arca nola
na navate vista delle l'aia ha dato sia
dato gesù madonna al karma che brutta
bestia occhio è un genio quel tizio mi
sa che non c'è riapre solo sì ci sono
arrivati perfetto cassa maroni che non
sei altro che lurido pezzente o
ragazzino così alla fine ci ha fatti
tutto il castello è eva bilanciate avido
lancia rigo va bene bilancio via fermi
tutti perché era questo lo dirà ci avete
fatta si si si sa non è completamente
scelto l'ospedale risalgo sopra io che
manca è aperto di sopra per occhio c'è
un buco lì come ci arriviamo
non ci arrivo portate qualcosa un
ripiano qualcosa take a ripiano per che
a voi farti sparago dentro
beh direi che ha funzionato con loro c'è
passato anche quello bianco bravi siete
completamente inutili al pene ma come
come aveva capito livello è finito il
livello perchè mi picchiate disastro di
gioco più stupido che abbia mai fatto ma
allo stesso tempo geniale ragazzi basta
direi che possiamo concludere qua è
stato bellissima pagato 15 euro
ne vale 4 3 ciao ragazzi che video vi
sia piaciuto il colosseo si precisa
quanto mi piace anche per i social
coniglio tradizione senza vestiti
scrivete che ci rivediamo non possiamo
vita per dare case
[Musica]